that love is a decision and not a  feeling  elaborate it's that same time as aquinas  said that to love is to will the good of  the other it's nothing about feelings  and this is an ancient medieval teaching  that actually comes from aristotle  that love philia is a is a positive  decision on the basis of who we are as  people and the dalai lama lives that  every single day he says you must decide  to love you must decide to love you  might not like martin luther king said  to like someone as a sentimental  something but to love somebody's a  positive decision it's hard it takes  work  it's a measure of who you are as a  person is your decision to love in a  world full of hate